[Music]
welcome to the ndsu carrington research
extension
center's organic tour we are standing on
the organic ground this is one of two
fields we have
um and this field has been certified
organic since uh
2007 excuse me 16.
anyway we're we're standing in front of
the wheat flax
inter crop trial and that's what i want
to talk to you about today now
intercropping is something that's become
very popular in most recent years and
particularly the last few
it's not a new concept although
intercropping has been done for years
it's been it's being done all around the
world particularly in many nations where
they where farmers are
not using a lot of inputs and so
in particular to also wheat flax
intercropping there's
there's information that goes back to
the 20s that show farmers in the dakotas
we're doing this
so it's not new we're not reinventing
the wheel but we're learning how to use
new technology and new tricks
to make it better intercropping wheat
flax
ironically as reported in our annual
report in 1991
was looked at in this research center
under conventional
plat ground from 1989 to 1991 by dr pat
carr
this this data showed in the early years
in the first couple years we looked at
uh at varying the rates of of
and excuse me varying the the role
arrangements and how it was
seated broadcast and stuff basically the
data showed
that it through economic analysis and
other factors
that it didn't pay and there was no
yield advantage
then a couple years later from 90 to 91
it was remodified and it was looked at
it from the standpoint of
of varying the seeding rates still not
concise of research although it did show
that in the
in that we in 1990 the flax yielded two
bushels to the acre
and and in 1991 we were getting seven
bushels to acre now that's significant
with showing a very little drop in yield
on the wheat
let's go to 2020. we're very we're
revising it again
but we're going into using it under
organic production
now organic flax is one of the crops
that we have found in our research out
here
that competes very poorly when we
compare it to conventional
plot yields many of the other crops such
as wheat and oats and barley
the yields are fairly comparable
particularly under years that are not
race horse years when conditions are not
as good
that is one thing that's been proven
when conditions are not as good
when we don't have perfect growing
conditions organic will be
much more comparable to conventional
plot yields our data shows us that here
from this research center
so why why are we looking at that we're
revising on the organic loan because
organic flax fetches a very high premium
for the organic farmer sometimes up to
30 dollars per bushel
but again as i mentioned we don't get
good yields under our flax
and so with that i thought
let's look at it with wheat and have
another crop there maybe the weeds will
be
will be better so this is where we're at
now um we
very simple design this year we have two
varieties in here
fbc dillon a variety that was developed
by the farm breeder club from northern
plains sustainable ag society
developed and released that was
developed under organic management
conditions
and glenn wheat an ndsu variety that has
been on high quality wheat for a number
of years now it's been replaced by np
vit vit pro as terms of the quality
check but still many farmer organic
farmers are planting this variety
then we went to omega flax which is our
yellow flax
which again organic farmers and
conventional of course too
are growing and getting a premium from
but particularly in the organic market
that is the variety that
organic farmers like to grow and then
our newest release nd hammond
named after dr jim hammond our previous
flax breeder
thank you jim for all your hard work so
we have
sole of each one of these the wheat is
seated as the seeding rate i use on
these plots
at 1.6 million pure live seed per acre
which it comes to about 110 to 120
pounds or two bushels
our flax here is seeded at
60 pounds to the acre and which is the
rate we use in organic production
organic production tends to use higher
seeding rates
than conventional doesn't mean that
conventional farming doesn't but we tend
to use higher seeding rates because we
need more plants for the competition
since we're not using
synthetic herbicides to control our
weeds we're using crop rotation
management and in factors like that to
control our weeds
now the other treatments we have here
we've we took now again this is fbc dill
and wheat on these two and we used
we used fbc dill and wheat at two thirds
of the rate and that flax at two thirds
of the rate
so that means we're at a million plants
per acre on the dillon and the flax is
at 43 pounds per acre ironically that's
about the same rates when i look in the
annual report
they use the first year they used 65
pounds to the acre and 32 pounds regular
very very close
and now again we have the same treatment
with glenn again with
the the lower rates two-thirds rates of
each one of the crops
um specifically after this year we'll
we'll fine-tune it
and and then start varying rates and
stuff like that but this is our first
proof-of-concept year
now ironically this year as you we look
in this plot here with with the dill and
wheat and the flax
you can hardly see the wheat the flax is
going to far out favor so the results
are not going to be the same
this can be this is due partially to the
drought the very dry conditions we're in
but it can also be to confound the issue
it can be our previous cover crop here
now we couldn't terminate the cover crop
because it was a rye
mixture with rye turnips um crimson
clover
and radishes that was the cover crop
because we were so wet last fall with
the
the the big rainfall and and we could
not terminate the crop so it had to be
terminated this spring
that can be confounding the issue with
the wheat the cereal crop
and that could be why the flax looks so
great if you take a shot and look at
this flax
this is a plot that has not been
harrowed we can't herald flax anyway
and it has not been hand weeded or
anything
i think any organic farmer would love to
have a field like this this goes against
everything i told you where i can't
weeds out compete me but it's it's going
to be a very exciting year to see what
happens here
and you know again not a new concept
that's been done forever we're just
revisiting it and trying to find new
tools and new varieties how to do this
and i ironically i want to read just a
quick verb from
the report that dr pat carr in 1991
annual report
his closing statement he says since it
remains
unclear how wheat flax inner cop inter
crops respond to plant population
changes additional research is planned
to determine how
inter-crop performance is influenced by
lower seeding rates
well dr pat carr you're a visionary just
like dr john gardner was
and so we're going to revisit this and
see what happens
we're going to find out ways that we can
make it better for your farm
so that you can get good returns on your
flax and have cleaner flax
and get better profit that's what we're
about here at the research area thank
you very much